I want to give you three sort of
suggestions which will I help you in all
kinds of questions of this category what
I love is that it's very easy to dream
up new versions of questions in geometry
because the limit is just your
imagination
but there are some principles that are
the same no matter what kind of shapes
or figures you're combining so here they
come
the first overarching tip is these are
maximum questions right so everything
that you have ever learned about Max min
applies so if you know when you think
about oh I get a function should I use
should I use the first derivative or the
second derivative to test the nature of
this whatever all that big flowchart
like of you just remember your training
going back to everything you already
knew about maximum questions and just
remember that these questions are a
subset of those so everything still
applies okay the second thing is you
know because it's geometry
okay diagrams are going to be involved
but I'm actually going to steal a
suggestion I gave to you back from
circle geometry which is that often in
circle geometry you can't see everything
on one diagram it's too much a mess of
lines and angles and all that kind of
thing you have to for example they're
part of your proof is to prove two
particular triangles are congruent
you're like there's like ten triangles
here which are the ones that matter so
you draw those two triangles you're
after off on the side so you can clearly
see which features match up multiple
diagrams are especially useful in these
questions as well because for the same
reason but you'll get more than just
circles okay so as you'll see in a
minute
for this particular question it's almost
I mean from my brain it's always
impossible to do without at least two
diagrams so draw draw more than one if
it helps you okay the last one is to
just watch out with the pruning rules
that you get in a question when when we
first introduced algebra we instantly
made everything harder because you're
like all right numbers five plus three
squared I can simplify three squared
it's a nine and five plus nine I can put
that together that's 14 so numbers all
naturally work themselves out but when
you've got pronumerals in the mirror
you know a plus x squared you can't do
anything with that it's as simple as it
gets
and so this increases the complexity of
what you have to deal with a large
proportion of the problems that we that
students encounter with these questions
are not problems at all with the concept
it's it's problems of performance like
you just get confused you lose a minus
sign underneath that just that take care
with this is to distinguish this is like
a sub point of this one is to
distinguish between constants and
variables
the reason I've chosen this particular
question is it's a perfect example where
you get a whole bunch of pruner was just
thrown at you you like all these
different letters some of them you
differentiate with respect to this right
because it makes sense because it varies
so this change but other the printables
are just there as as stand-ins what
we're trying to say is you know what
what you're about to prove is true with
with a cone of any dimension right so it
doesn't have to be hype this and radius
that they just provide our H as the
height r is the radius and you have to
make sure you don't mix these two guys
up okay so the very first thing we're
going to do is we question eight in
front of you they do provide very nicely
they provide a diagram for you and as
you know that's no excuse not to draw
your own rhyme because as you draw you
understand what's going on better so the
very first thing we're going to do is
replicate in some ways this diagram and
think about it as we go so read with me
it says a cylinder of height H and
radius R is inscribed in a cone of and
then it tells you a few things about the
cone okay so let's just make a quick
note about the word inscribed because
this happens this comes up a lot what do
we all have a sense for the idea of
something being inscribed in another if
you just quickly draw under here for
instance the most common things you
inscribe in circles but you can inscribe
one shape within any other kind it looks
like this if I say I will inscribe a
triangle within this circle okay
this triangle is not inscribed it's not
inscribed right
it's inside what makes it inscribed is
that it's the largest version of this
triangle that I can fit inside right
when I say version I mean it's similar
to okay so for instance while this is
not inscribed let's see here's this
triangle which is similar has all the
same proportions and that kind of theme
even the weird curvy edges that are not
meant to be curved
this guy is inscribed okay because
there's no you can't make this any
larger and still have it similar to the
original triangle okay so that's what
inscribed means so when you have a look
at this you can see this is the biggest
cylinder of these particular proportions
that you can jam inside this cone if you
were to make this cylinder any larger it
would break the code okay so before I
even start to draw this since there are
two shapes I'm going to draw this in two
different colors I'm gonna do the cone
in one color and I'm gonna do the
cylinder in another so let's do that now
and please make this big enough okay
let's have a look what do you think
how does it look at the moment okay you
can see I've done a few things here I've
drawn it yes I've drawn it horrendously
large but you know it's it's better to
have one too big then I have one too
small and then you're like oh I've got a
I've got to add stuff in here and now I
need to draw a new diagram and repeat it
so I've got everything there you'll
notice I've color-coded it as well so my
current and everything that pertains to
the cone is black so I've got my cone
I've got behind the cone the Rays of the
cone and then I've got my cylinder in
blue and everything related to the
cylinder also blue it has its own radius
and its own height which are somewhat
independent of the cone all right now
we've begun here with our first diagram
I'm gonna go straight to this last
suggestion I made here to take care with
these pronumerals read the question
carefully and tell me what varies and
what is constant any any any pointers
have a look the question itself tells
you tell me the constants first what's
fixed the now you have to be very
specific because I heard height and I
heard radius but
I have two heights and two radius so
which one are we talking about okay
the cone is fixed so over here under you
can even put the heading of consonants
somewhere like the top right hand corner
of your working right if you say
Constance I'm going to say little R and
little H and just to clarify that for
myself I'm going to say cone okay so
these do not change so for example you
couldn't do something like say the
derivative of the volume with respect to
little R because it's not changing like
it's there's no there's this is change
in volume change in middle R and it
doesn't change so that doesn't make
sense okay so I'm trying to avoid errors
here a lot of students they come up with
expressions related to this and they try
and differentiate with the shape to that
that implies what the what the variables
are right what are the variables big R
and big H which are of course the
cylinder now I put both of those down
because the question is told me however
as you'll see if you if you're having a
look at the scaffold that they provide R
and H are not just they're not
completely independent are they right if
you change R for instance let's have a
look look at the diagram for a second if
I made our smaller so I'm making this
cylinder thinner right in order for the
cylinder to stay inscribes right if all
I did was make it thinner and didn't
change the height it would not be
inscribed anymore would it right because
I make that narrower you know I but I
have more space to go I could I could
increase right so if I do change the
radius and make it smaller what happens
to the height of the cylinder yeah it
gets taller does it it would go deeper
inside the cone in fact the the smaller
capital R is the closer
capital H gets to little H does that
make sense if there were if it were
possible to make a cylinder of zero
radius it would go right down the middle
and important HS would be the same make
sense so that's why you can see Part A
says use similar triangles to show that
and then there's a relationship between
all four of these variables now look
carefully before we embark on doing this
you have to ask the question of why why
why is this a thing
because in another question I might if I
wanted to make this question harder for
you I would simply take away the
scaffold Part C find the maximum
possible volume of the cylinder in terms
of H and our Part C is the real question
okay
a and B are just sort of to help you get
there so if I wanted to make this
question harder I would take away a as a
clue so now I'm gonna ask you why is a
helpful why
what is it getting us towards what do
you think what an advantage do I have
once I have Part A interesting let me
rewind for a second differentiation
right because we said this is just like
everything we've ever seen before right
a very common thing you've already been
doing is say for example you've got the
area of like a paddock right there
that's a common one and you're changing
the length of the fences or something
like that like so okay so you
differentiate one thing with respect to
another but of course you can only do
that if you have the area if you have
the area so Li is a function of a single
variable right like if it's a
rectangular paddock and it's got a um a
height and a width so you say our area
equals height times width
well you can't differentiate that
because you have two things right which
what you're differentiating with respect
to so you have to get it in terms of one
variable right now have a look again at
Part A what they're asking you to do is
get capital H get this guy in terms of
this guy right that's that's the first
step of solving equations by
substitution once you've got that you
can get rid of capital H you can replace
it with stuff that's just in terms of
our okay so they say use similar
triangles to do similar triangles I'm
gonna go to suggestion number two I'll
pause for a minute and let you have a
play with this first yourself without me
telling you what diagram could you put
alongside this that will help you
identify similar triangles there aren't
any triangles in my diagram at all right
now
so you kind of have to find them first
I'm gonna give you a couple minutes to
have a bit of a play around
and see if you can find where the
triangles are that will get you this
relationship off you go see what you
find